the live feed in particular because this  is board i don't know this is on board  one this is part three but yeah it's  it's of course the he's going back he's  gone rook a3  judging by what i saw on my screen  trying to defend but uh yeah can you  really defend  yeah it's going to k3 it's not in my top  three lines on on my screen it's  probably not not the greatest move in  the world  but they are they are going to be  playing pretty much an increment yeah it  is  it ticked down to like 10 seconds or  thereabouts  three seconds okay and  okay you could  i only just realized you can take on a3  yeah you can yes if you want you can you  should  and you should and black is doing  extremely well after it somehow rook f6  king g7 rook takes b6 i guess  and we have to find a way to continue  here with black  just to give our viewers you know  some idea of how